hello folks
welcome to rational science
live from frankfurt germany today we
have
an exciting day we're going to be doing
warp triangles now
how much more exciting can he get than
that okay
but before i get into that uh let me do
a little bit of extinction try some
loose ends on extinction
and here it goes uh some questions that
comments that people made okay ah
went through the other side sometimes it
happens
okay here goes uh fellow says
if an economic collapse comes flee to
the nearest
amish community and offer your services
as a night watch guard
well the problem is that one uh defense
see the amish don't have
defense right now you could say they
take their defense
for granted you know they have the
police national guard army the whole
works
and they have the courts okay and so
if there's a problem you know you just
use these uh
mechanisms these uh resources
and you get justice you get protection
but when the whole thing collapses
there won't be any government there
won't be any police
there won't be any courts everybody's on
his own
and the amish will probably be the last
to find out
because they try not to keep in contact
with those folks
outside their walls and so yeah
what you can say is that when the whole
thing collapses
uh there will be thousands of people who
realize that they don't have any food
and there's no food
forthcoming and so they're going to be
rushing to the nearest place
you can imagine all those little towns
out there in pennsylvania
ohio indiana you know and so on uh
you know they're full of amish perhaps
mennonites
and they're going to be swamped
by all the people in the cities the
people on the other side i think they
call them the english
because they're all german all these
amish and so the
english will uh try to make the most
of what the uh amish did you know
planted
and now they're not gonna go out there
and say look let us train you on how to
farm now there won't be any time for
that it's just going to be slaughter
uh it's just going to be mass murder
okay and yeah the last people to find
out will be people like the amish the
indians the natives
lost tribes those will be the last the
first to go
okay people uh know about them you know
i've been in the jungles of uh
of the amazon lost tribes
and i think it's easy to hunt them down
with guns
you know these people some some lost
tribes out there still use bows and
arrows and
darts and that kind of stuff hammers you
know
clubs uh they'll be the first to go
okay people know about him and
uh really what what's going to happen
first probably is
people are going to rush to forests and
jungles and whatever and kill the
animals first
and whatever they think they can eat and
then from then on you know they'll be
human against human when there's nothing
left
that's what happened by the way with the
dinosaurs you know they say nothing
larger than a cat survived and that's
because you know the big guys started
eating the little guys
it was mass murder that's all i can tell
you
okay so yeah you don't want to hire
yourself as a security guard because uh
you're gonna be on your own uh and
that's even if the
amish would be willing to hire you which
probably they wouldn't they wouldn't
have any need to hire you
okay they wouldn't understand why they
need to hire you
okay here's uh here's another question
issue
uh says usd collapsing doesn't mean
bitcoin collapse at the same time uh
lead in hemp can be money too you are
going to have
a hard time getting rid of all the money
the basic idea that money disappears is
the greatest mistake in the whole thing
learn about cryptocurrency says another
fellow these people think that
cryptocurrency is not currency that it's
some kind of
that's not money that it's something
else no money can be anything just like
that guy just said there
you know money can be gold and silver
used to be gold silver
used to be food you know like i said uh
ruth in the bible she was paid with
barbie uh for her and her mother-in-law
so yeah what you have is um
food can be uh money can be anything
and so it's not an issue of of you know
you're saying well we're gonna change
green money for brown money no no that
that's not gonna save you money will
disappear
in all in all forms meaning trade
will be no more no one will trade
okay that's the the issue and nobody
will trade because
money has disappeared and
that's you know trade is money money is
trade
money is simply some form of currency
medium of exchange
but what i'm saying is trade will be no
more there won't be any trade because
money will be no more
and nobody will want to trade uh when
there is no money because the only
thing of value will be food
and no one trades food when true food is
the only
thing of value you want food you don't
want to give it away
but people think oh i'll exchange my my
car
for a month worth of food
obviously you have never uh been a
hunter gatherer you know
hunter gathers know better they know
that when you're out there alone in the
jungle
you trust no one first there's no one to
help you out there's no 9-1-1 to call
you're on your own
you got to defend yourself and you got
to defend your stock of food
if you have too much of it well maybe a
lot of people want to share in your
bounty you know and
i don't know if you'll be willing to
share it with them
and i don't mean trade i mean sharing it
like you know
one person's amount of food will be
shared among 10
that'll never happen now they're just
going to kill each other for that food
that's what's gonna happen uh it's
happened before
all over history when people were
starving to death by the way
okay uh another
file says money is not real it is a
representation of what is real
money also represents purchasing power
production
uh creates money money does not create
production your theory on human
extinction and you
add mammals too would result from the
disappearance of the trade yeah
and you had today money disappears and
nobody will trust
any more in money uh yeah
okay you say that this is an assumption
a hypothesis
well but then why do you say that do not
ask
if but when so saying it becomes
prediction
which in your rational science is
prohibited
okay we got to put this in the right
context people confuse things here
the theory of extinction my theory of
extinction says the following
let's make sure we have it we're saying
that this is what's going to happen
there's going to be an
overturning of the ecological pyramid
okay essentially the primary production
disappears
um whatever the big animals the rulers
of the planet ate i mean the herbivores
right the big ones
uh whatever they ate suddenly not
suddenly but
geologically suddenly okay becomes
uh smaller and smaller they become
smaller and smaller
islands these forests these jungles they
become smaller and smaller islands
and at some point it reaches critical
mass
and the animals cannot survive on
whatever is left
and that's when they go when they go the
predators who preyed upon them well they
go as well
that's essentially the theory okay uh
what i'm doing right now is explaining a
theory i'm explaining a
mechanism that's all i did so far okay
now what am i gonna do with this
well i'm gonna project it to the future
i'm going to say let's project it to man
can man avoid the same
mechanism the same process that's the
question
okay so um
we make uh we we produce uh our own
um uh food okay and distribute it
and and so what do i say well
i say that all mass extinctions where
the result of food collapses
including the one that's going to happen
to man and
catastrophic mechanisms cannot explain
the only thing an extinction theory has
to explain which is selectivity
okay uh and so that applies to man as
well
and so what's the issue the issue is
let's assume
let's assume that the klingons come and
visit us
thousands of years into the future okay
so they come here to the earth
and they find out that oh there used to
be something we'll call
humans around and they're no longer
around they died just
or they died as much as all the
species before them so they look at
these humans which are
you know the skeletons they find in the
rock and they say well how did they die
well maybe they died the same way as all
the other animals died they died in a
mass extinction which is what
the collapse of the ecological pyramids
the overturning of the ecological
pyramid
so they have an explanation for how
humans died
explain we can only explain the past we
do not explain
the future prediction has to do with
future
explain has to do with past and what i'm
saying
is that we're we're talking about a
mechanism we're talking about an
explanation of a mechanism of how humans
will disappear because humans cannot do
anything about the mechanism that i'm
proposing
so i'm talking about a mechanism i'm not
talking about a prediction
and that's very hard for some people to
understand because they're
so used to the wording of mathematical
physics and they say
well prediction has to do with the
future we're predicting something
that's going to happen and you're saying
that something is going to happen
well i'm putting it in the context of
past
tense i'm explaining what's going to
happen
and i always give the example of
a an eclipse
okay we have the moon going around the
earth and blocking the sunlight okay and
so we say look
tomorrow tomorrow there's gonna be an
eclipse
is that a prediction so far yes it's a
prediction
okay if i can explain why
if i can explain why how come
there's gonna be an eclipse
i'm no longer predicting now i'm talking
about the past
i'm explaining i'm drawing from my
experience
from something i saw something i you
know
something someone told me okay so i'm
going to
talk about a theory of why
an eclipse happens that's why i know
to use that term that tomorrow there's
going to be an eclipse
i'm not talking about the prediction i'm
talking about the
explanation the mechanism that causes an
eclipse
that's the context here i'm saying that
humans are going to die
they're going to disappear they're going
to become extinct because they're going
to become extinct in the same way the
animals in the past
became extinct that's the mechanism and
they cannot do anything about it
that's why it's going to happen because
we
can't do anything about it
that's the context okay now
one of the problems i have is here
extinction 102
no one asks questions or really answers
questions
regarding extinction 101. no one deals
with
past animals because they don't do
research on it on this subject they
probably don't care about it
and so they say well yeah we don't know
how the animals died but i can tell you
that man is not going to die because the
of the food collapse or the money
collapse or whatever
they all know we how we won't disappear
how we won't become extinct
no one can tell you how we will become
extinct
that's the problem so before you tell me
how
that we won't disappear because of money
or because of food
tell me how we will disappear
will man live forever and if you say
well the sun will explode hey first of
all that's forever
second you can also argue that we're
going to leave the planet and
be in some other solar system so that's
not a guaranteed
mechanism which means that we will
live forever that's what your argument
is
you're not giving me an a mechanism of
extinction
this is what we need from you if you're
a scientist
you don't say this is not how man will
not die you tell us
how man will die objections and
criticisms are not science science
consists of explanations of mechanism
especially in in the case of physics so
we need to for you to tell us
how man will die which is extinction 102
and it would really help if you can tell
us to show us that
you really are an expert on the subject
tell us how the animals in the past died
extinction 101 okay and yeah the big
problem i have
are uh in general right is that
people don't understand that if money
disappears
food disappears a lot of people don't
understand that and for me it's just
it's mind blowing that i mean you don't
have to agree with it
i'm not talking about agreement i'm
saying that people don't understand that
if money happens to disappear
you know food disappears they don't
understand that
i have a little uh picture that
synthesizes that
i don't know if these it'll sink in
their brains because these people
obviously have serious problems
they don't need a physicist they need a
psychiatrist that's what they need
and here's here's the picture okay and
here we have the chain of money on the
left okay and what we have is that we
have workers on the bottom
lower uh left there and
they go to the market and they spend the
salaries they want
they got from their producers okay and
they spend it on the market
and the market relies on someone to
deliver
uh the food to them so that they can
put it in the shelves and they have to
pay the delivery guys
the delivery company and the delivery
company gets it from whom from the
manufacturer
okay someone who processes maybe cans it
or whatever
and they have to pay those people to do
it sometimes it's the same company
and so it's just internal and the
manufacturer
has to get it from the producer the
agricultural company that grows it and
uh you know
distributes it to the manufacturer and
the producer here includes both you know
all um
corporations so this is the chain
of money this is how money circles more
or less around
our economy our global and our
artificial
human economy what happens if we
get rid of all the chains what happens
if we get rid of the chain
of money and we rely
then on faith we have the chain of faith
now
now uh the
the proletariat the worker he doesn't
get money from the
producer he has no money to spend at the
market
the market has no money to pay the
delivery guy
you know especially if they're not going
to make any money
by selling to the consumers the delivery
guy has no reason to deliver
okay the manufacturer has no
uh incentive to produce because there is
no money
and a producer has no incentive to sell
or to send
to the manufacturer because he's getting
no money
and again cycle completes because the
producer now hasn't doesn't have any
incentive
to pay any salaries because there's
nothing to sell
so the issue here is not whether you
believe in any of this the issue here is
whether
you understand that without money this
whole thing doesn't work
okay and it's so hard to
to get people just to understand what
i'm saying here it's not it's just
unbelievable
because we're not talking about belief
we're talking about understanding a
mechanism
i'm saying that god does not have to
send you know
waters over on the earth for 40 days and
40 nights like he did with noah uh
he's a little more advanced these days
now you know he says
i'm gonna go in there you know wave my
magic wand
and i'm gonna make money disappear you
know
i'm gonna make sure that no one trusts
in god anymore
okay god we don't trust and so
he waves his magic wand and for some
miracle okay right now we're just gonna
make an assumption we're gonna rely on
this miracle we're gonna say god makes
money disappear will anyone produce food
will corporations produce food will they
sell it to the manufacturer to the
person to the companies that process
food
will they sell it to the delivery guy
will they sell it to the markets will
they sell it to the consumer
if money is no more now you have
outlawed money
uh by you know just waving of the magic
wand
so the only thing i i need for people to
understand here is
not whether you believe it but whether
you understand that without money
this world doesn't run and people don't
understand that
and again we're not talking about
whether trade will disappear whether
you trust that whether you believe that
it's going to disappear
we're not there yet we can't get to that
point because right now people don't
even understand that even if that were
to happen
you'd you'd say well still food would be
around
where we would still produce food or i'm
going to know my farming i'm going to
produce food on my own
we have all these arguments like if 8
billion people on a planet could go out
there who live in apartments
could go out there and start planting on
their own uh plot of land
and wait four months for food to grow
you know is that gonna happen and we're
gonna work all together and kiss each
other and say hey let's all work
together you get
you grab the hole i'll grab the shovel
and uh and the other guy
you know the uh the bulls and we're
gonna
plow the land and start working the land
uh
for all of us we're gonna be become
eight billion amish
working the land sure
now no i'll tell you what's gonna happen
we're gonna kill each other
and it may not be in our best interest
but that's what we're gonna do
people are not going to sit back and say
well no that's wrong we can't kill each
other because that's only going to make
the situation worse
uh yeah tell that to the gangs that are
running around you know starving and
realizing the situation it's just gonna
be murder
it can be slaughtered okay infighting is
known that's how it's
that's how the dinosaurs also killed
each other you know as long as they had
uh the t-rexes had triceratops to eat
no problem but when those were gone it
was you know t-rex against t-rex
it was uh infighting after that
okay um
when fellow says last comment here says
animals didn't go extinct because they
ran out of food they went extinct
because they forgot to eat
okay every animal forgetting to eat
makes just as much sense
as everybody refusing to use money
okay that's his argument well uh
it's not the same uh it's not that we
forget
to trade it's not that we forget to use
money or that we don't want to
or unilaterally and decide hey i'm not
going to use money anymore
that's not what i'm proposing at all i'm
saying it's going to be shoved down our
throats
whether we like it or not okay money
will have no value and so nobody will
accept
money it's not that you unilaterally say
well i'm not going to use money anymore
you know i'm not going to use my
bitcoins or my gold or my
greenbacks to buy stuff that's not what
i'm saying
i'm saying you won't be able to use it
because the other guy won't accept it
because he won't be able to do anything
with that
it's like uh you know you're go back to
the flintstone age you're gonna be
paying him with rocks and the guy says
i don't want rocks what can i do with
rocks that's more or less
what i'm saying but again i can't get
that far because right now we have
an intermediate problem and that problem
is that people still don't understand
that without money we will not produce
food
that part for me it's just mind-blowing
that people won't understand it
but for me that's a mental block and
people have
some mental problems if they don't
understand that
and yeah i guess lack of intuition i
don't know
what else to call it okay so uh
that's my two cents bid today on
extinction
and until i get an answer on extinction
101
i got to stop there and that's one issue
the other one is you know if people
don't understand it without money there
won't be any food
not that you believe it i'm just talking
about a mechanism here
uh if you don't understand that well
there's no purpose in talking about
the disappearance of money because
people say well i don't care if money
disappears because like i said you know
without money
there still will be food and if we don't
understand that
there's no purpose in talking about the
disappearance of money
just that simple okay let's move on here
and uh i'm going to cover another
subject which is
apparently has not been settled and
that's the issue of
observation in science we do not observe
we do not use the word observation at
all the word observation belongs to
religion okay we do not observe we do
not
gawk in science and people say
well how can you explain something if
you have not
observed it and i don't know how many
times i'm going to cover this subject
it's unbelievable that people have
you know again mental problems in
understanding this and i'm talking about
understanding okay so
let's go with some of the issues the
questions how will you know what to
explain if you haven't observed anything
to explain
again that's that synthesizes more or
less what people have going through
their
heads katie thinks science has no
connection to the real
observed world i don't know where he got
that again misunderstanding shows that
not he's not paying attention okay and
yet you observe that light was fast
hence
hypothesizing invisible torsion observed
that electric currents have magnetic
fields
hence hypothesizing swinging intangible
serpentines
observe that gravity is unblockable etc
are you going to pretend that your
hypothesis and all its nuances
pop out of thin air to explain a totally
imaginary world
okay and let me continue with some of
the other questions that people
said along those same lines so that we
get them all there okay
they continue and says you go to the
conference conference as you put it
and present and explain your invisible
intangible mechanism okay what relevance
does the mechanism have to
anything if you do not include the
visible
visible intangible right observation
that's what he's referring to
another foul says you say look i can
explain how these two magnets
etc bill you just made an observation
my god and the other fellow says how the
hell can you
immediately jump to a belief or
hypothesis without having made
an observation this is what's on
all these people's minds what is the
problem
well the problem is context
these people are not understanding the
context it takes them two years to find
out what the context is i don't know how
else to explain it
these people are talking about the
scientific
so-called scientific method that they
learned by wrote in high school or in
college
and that dates to the 17th century the
so-called 17th century
scientific revolution well it wasn't
scientific at all
it was a religious revolution and we're
still doing religion
no one is doing science because no one
has the scientific
method yet okay so so we have a problem
we haven't defined what science is
and we do not have a scientific method
what we have is a method
of what of research we have a
method of research and the question if
the process of researching
is amounts to science
and i always give the example you study
all week
and then you fail the test on friday
okay so the fact that you studied that
you did
research that you swallowed all these
books that you observed and predicted
and
you know hypothesized and theorized
and you go to the take the test on
friday and you failed
you did not know so
what was all that research about if you
did not learn anything
his research the same thing as science
see these people think that science is
this
eternal process of research
of you know includes several steps and
that it leads to
whatever to a point where they start
again they say well
now we reach this point now let's
continue studying
and do all these steps again and you
reach a point then you continue studying
and you reach another point you
can continue studying and so on add
infinitum
so we have a problem because uh the
question is
whether research is equal to science
that's the issue the second part of that
is that
um that's the the so-called scientific
method which is really
the method of religion includes
persuasion
they think it's a question of proving to
the jury
jury of peers uh what you what your
findings are
and aside from the fact that the
findings are not explanations the
findings are really descriptions usually
mathematical descriptions
the question is whether persuasion
is science so we have research
and persuasion do those two amount to
science this is where the problem is
okay so let's uh put this on on the
board so
so we can see it
okay these are the observation
conclusions that i put the other day we
have a method of research
versus the method of explaining
rationally
these are two different things method of
research
and uh persuasion i'll include that in
there
that doesn't amount to science what
amounts to sciences method of explaining
in a case of physics something
mechanically in other words you have to
explain the mechanism
how mother nature does gravity how
mother nature does magnetism that's what
we're trying to explain
we're trying to explain that invisible
world the visible stuff we already know
about why
because we've observed fine i don't care
we have the explanations we we have
explanations for the visible stuff
we don't have explanations rational
explanations for the invisible stuff
and the main reasons we do not have no
one proposes objects
objects that exist which are the big
problems and i'll get to that in a
second
so we have a method of research is
irrational
whereas explanations
are something different okay and the
explanations that we have from
mathematical physics especially
are not explanations their descriptions
uh put in the guise
of explanations okay we have no
explanations and that gets us to the
issue
that explanations are defined as
description some of these people think
that descriptions and
explanations are synonyms and they're
not a description
is not an explanation explanation is not
a description or a set of descriptions
or anything
related to description that's where you
got to start
because if you think that explanation
descriptions are synonyms then you got a
problem
especially when some people like uh i
posted in the past uh donald simonek he
says
science is not explaining science is
describing
so apparently this uh emeritus professor
thinks that there is a difference
between explaining and describing
and at least there he's right whether he
understands what the difference is
that's a different issue
but he realized that explaining and
description describing are not
synonyms and what we have today are
descriptions we don't have explanations
and what we do have are irrational
so-called explanations because they're
dismissed as philosophy they don't care
about that they care about the
descriptions
okay so yeah and then studying doesn't
mean understanding
okay method of persuasion is religion
again
okay and it's irrelevant subjective to
begin an explanation
of a mechanism by saying that i observed
you don't begin in a conference saying
i observed because right now when you
say that whether you did or not is
irrelevant
so let me state that all these people
who say you cannot explain without
observing
irrelevant irrelevant irrelevant i don't
care if you
if you did observe it's irrelevant
you don't begin your explanation of a
mechanism saying
i observed nobody cares if you observed
or not
nobody cares it's not part of the
explanation the explanation has to be
objective
when you say i observed and i'm going to
show that in a second why
you have a problem if you use the word
observe but
when you say i observe you're
introducing testimony
it's like you're in a witness uh in a
trial you say i observed
well you observed does the jury believe
uh
you because you say that you observed
keep that in mind i'm getting to that in
a second okay
and besides the fact that you need not
have observed by the way to explain a
mechanism that's one issue
and then uh the the other issue is that
some people you know like i i talk about
stephen hawking he never observed a
black hole doesn't mean
that he cannot explain a mechanism
involving a black hole he makes an
assumption then he explains it with that
he doesn't have to have observe the
black hole
okay so keep all these things in mind
and sometimes you observe in
what was your state of mind did you
observe
the spirit move the the curtain
or was it maybe the air so you say i
observed the spirit
i observed god come down to earth i
observed the et's come down to earth and
build the pyramids
you did not observe this but people say
observe because they're trying to
introduce
testimony okay so that's another issue
here that's floating around
okay so what we have is a difference
between a
method of research and persuasion
okay and these are the steps and of
course when you do this it's known as
religion
the first step you say well you have to
observe before you can explain
and so what you're doing is really
introducing subjectivity
because we don't need to say that you
observed a phenomenon whether you did or
not
to explain a phenomenon objectively
okay and here we have
the true genuine scientific method where
do you see in there
observe observation we have a hypothesis
which are the assumptions
it includes the objects that are going
to be mediating the transactions the
phenomena
we have the definitions you have to have
definitions otherwise we don't really
know what you're
saying when you're using those words and
then you have the initial scene you know
you got to
prepare the groundwork for your theory
okay and then you tell your theory which
is essentially in physics
mechanisms causes okay that's what it's
all about
okay so uh here we have
um you know one guy said the other day
what if i film an event again
observation right because
whether you do with a camera with your
eyes doesn't matter you're going to
present this
and you're going to say here here's a
movie i mean you can't deny this
and you're kind of insinuating to the
jury that hey you gotta accept it
because
not only did i see it and i observed it
i filmed it i bring it here to you for
you to see
and so here um here i filmed
uh this observation okay i filmed
this fellow his name is um
felix the cat and i want you to see what
he does
grabs a brick okay goes in there
and just throws it through the window
i mean i filmed it okay
i was there i filmed it any questions
it turns out that um i was there
but you weren't and you're the juror
one of them we have 12 jurors
and half of them from china or from
greece or from some other place
they they weren't there and i show them
i say look this is how the window broke
a brick was thrown through the window
well i know because you know i was there
and i filmed it
but they say well i wasn't there i i
don't know if that film is for real
i don't trust your observation i mean
with a film
it still gives you more credibility but
imagine i didn't film it
then i say well a brick went through the
window
do they have to believe me because i say
i observed
does that make any difference am i
trying to influence the jury by saying
i observed i'm just testifying i'm
people think that science is like a
trial uh where people can present
witnesses
testimony and they say i observe well if
he says you observe
who's going to doubt him and yet people
lie on the witness land don't they you
know they're
they commit perjury it's known as
perjury okay
so uh do should we uh believe
a film well uh here i'm gonna present
another film okay
and uh we have a juror a jury
of 12 flat earthers okay and we show
them this
ah give me a second here i went on the
other side
sometimes it falls overboard it goes to
the other side of it
okay this is what i show this was filmed
uh real time according to nasa
and we have these astronauts on the moon
we have
many pictures of these guys in space and
on the moon and everywhere
uh so i show it to a panel
of flat earthers 12 flat earthers now
look i filmed it
nasa you know this is you got to believe
them these are professionals
phds they're supported by the government
by your taxes
uh you got to believe them who's going
to doubt it
do you think the flat earthers will
believe it i just showed him a movie
i say it was filmed real time
maybe 1968 1969 right
and they say well i wasn't there i don't
believe it i think it was made in
hollywood
and i mean and thank god they filmed it
because if they hadn't filmed it and i
just said look i observed i was there
you know a little man says
80 years old now says i was there i you
know i i found it
or maybe one of the astronauts who's
still around he said look i was there i
was jumping on the moon
i give you my testimony i was not only
observed i was doing it
uh will they believe
will have you convinced the jury of flat
earthers
and if you did not then what the po
what was the point of introducing the
word observe into your
testimony into your into your
explanation
if instead you say look let us assume
you know this picture this movie is man
jumping on the moon okay we can see the
assumption
it's just an assumption so far we don't
have to believe it we don't have to not
believe it
belief plays no part so far you make an
assumption you say let us assume man
went to the moon
i'm this guy i was jumping on the moon
that's the assumption now you're going
to explain maybe gravity
maybe something else you can explain the
theory
with that you did not have to say at all
at under no circumstances i
observed i was there i did it
that's testifying yeah it's like saying
that you were there when they built the
pyramids and you saw the
et's build the pyramid i was there i
observed
that's all you're saying you're
testifying testimony is
outlawed in science observation
versus your observation meaning with the
eyes is outlawed in science i don't care
if you did
observe or not we do not begin an
explanation by saying
i observed and i'm not sure how else to
tell you all this
okay okay where does this take us
well first of all uh the
so-called scientific method the one from
the 17th century
i showed it this the other day you have
all these irrational
conclusions and theories that we have
today and you can go through them later
on
but there you can read them they're all
irrational one is more irrational than
the other one
okay so if that's the scientific method
including observation and led us to
these
theories these conclusions then uh well
you read your own
conclusion uh how much observation is
worth
in science okay maybe that's so-called
scientific method which includes
observation
is not science at all because we ended
up with these uh
irrational conclusions
okay uh one file says one more
issue here uh he says
a belief can be true or false hypothesis
is defined as justified belief that
is not known to be true not
known to be true okay known by whom by
the pope or
who dalai lama maybe i don't know who's
got to determine that it's true who who
is the judge
okay thus a hypothesis is a belief
that is backed up with some supporting
evidence
evidence okay for evidence for whom
you know what is evidence to you for
truth for me that same is evidence for
false
observation experiment but it still may
be false
okay so all you said is that whatever
the guy said whatever he proposed
could be false could be true could be
false we still don't know it depends on
your opinion
on your upbringing on your state of mind
on so many things and
so far you said nothing a theory is a
substantiated explanation
for an occurrence that has come to a
conclusion
to a conclusion conclus so someone put a
stop and says
you should investigate anymore
okay a judgment or decision reached by
reasoning
though not unimpeachable well you
stopped it you said it has come to a
conclusion to a stop to a
dead stop but you say it may not be
uh unimpeachable
so what's different between the theory
and the hypothesis apparently
both are proposals backed by some
evidence or without
and they both are impeachable
they both could be false so what have
you
distinguished between hypothesis and
theory seemed to be the same thing one
guy says
assuming a hypothesis in this case is a
theory because that's
essentially he's saying it's a belief
i'm not sure
what belief has to do with science
but essentially he's saying it's an
explanation
a person has for which he says there's
not enough evidence
okay with some supporting evidence and
the other one says
a little more supporting evidence but
they both could be false
so you see that these people have no
clue whatsoever they've never defined
these terms hypothesis and theory
in fact today theory is the same thing
as a hypothesis they think they're
synonyms
except for the fact that hypothesis is
also taken to be a prediction
an assumption a description hypothesis
is everything
in other words the word hypothesis has
never been defined because it's so broad
it
incorporates everything it's a
prediction the same thing as
an explanation is a description the same
thing as an assumption
these are the issues you got a result so
in your religion hypothesis equals
theory
that's a that's my conclusion because
there's no difference both can be false
opinion belief
a hypothesis becomes a theory by casting
ballots you vote for it
okay every fifty percent plus one that
makes it
converts the hypothesis into a theory is
that what it is
voting and voting also more theory into
fact
you turn it into a fact that you say
well we came to a conclusion
you know like uh they came to conclusion
on black hole that's not challengeable
anymore they came to a conclusion on
dark matter that cannot be challenged
anymore because
it's no longer a theory now it's a fact
uh they have this dark energy
uh was proven to be true a fact in 1998
that's what these
folks that came with that idea gun won
the nobel prize for
okay and so um
it's now a fact now you can't challenge
it
you know it's it's no longer a theory
now it's a fact it's truth
you have to believe in it and again it
shows that
all that has nothing to do with science
it has to do with religion
first we have an irrational theory
proposal and then you're supposed to
believe it
which again has to do with religion not
with science science we do not believe
science we explain and we understand
and that's when science that's where we
draw the line on science
what continues on the other side of that
line is known as belief opinion
that's known as religion this side of
science
it's only objective uh explanation
of a mechanism where do we take all this
where
where do all these notions pop into the
minds of these poor folk
well they pop into their minds because
of two words
the word object and the word exist
that's why we've never settled what an
object is
and what the word exist means that's why
they talk about
observation they want hands-on they want
to go to the lab and do something
okay they want to touch
and see and prove through experience
through
intuition through whatever you know
maybe measurement
and calculations they think all that
science
so let's uh show why these people are so
wrong and why
observation has nothing whatsoever to do
with science
okay it's because of the definition of
the word object and exist
i'm going to put a little picture here
and i'm going to talk in the background
and let's see if you can follow along
okay so please try to pay attention
here he goes okay we have the earth on
one side of the universe and we have the
klingons
clinton on land on the other side of the
universe okay
and they're one gazillion light years
apart we have no chance i've ever seen
these guys we can't see them we can't
touch them
okay we're so far apart we're not we're
not even close
we can't see them we're touching we
cannot smell them hear them
nothing we can't even send signals to
them
okay so now here on earth that's you on
earth in the uh
yellowish uh brownish
coloring and you have a table near you
in your house does i ask you is that
table
a physical object and you say well yes
it is
yes it's a physical object and i ask you
why is it a physical object
well because i can see and i can touch
it
okay does it exist yes
why well because i can see it and i can
touch it
see the word exists and the word object
are synonyms to all these people
they think that an object is that which
you can touch and see
or see and uh in a uh exists
means that you can touch or see it
okay it turns out that you cannot see or
touch
the table that the klingon has i asked
the klingon if i could ask him
mr klingon does that table that you have
near you does that ex
is that an object and he would say yeah
that is an object
why well because i can see and i can
touch it
okay does it exist yes
why well because i can see and i can
touch it
and it turns out that the guy on the
left he cannot see or touch the
klingons table and the klingon cannot
see or touch
the table that the guy on the left has
the human
and so now here's the million dollar
questions two questions
is the table that the klingon has is
that an
object yes or no is it an object for
the human on earth and uh you might
answer well no it's not an object for
him because he cannot see or touch it
does it exist well no because he cannot
see
or touch it so we have a problem because
it turns out that
here we have a table that the klingon
says exists and that is an object
because he can see and touch it
but you cannot see or touch it so you
say that it's not an object
and it doesn't exist by definition and
vice versa
you know uh your table you know the
klingon hand not see or touch it and so
on and so forth
so we have a problem with the
definitions of object
and exist because we cannot use them
consistently
and they become subjective they become
subjected
to seeing and touching
so this pencil is an object not because
it has
shape but because i can see it and i can
touch it
but for the klingon this is not a pencil
just not an object
because he can't see or touch it does it
exist no
because he can't see or touch it so we
have a problem with the definitions here
we have a we have we can't continue
using
the object notion that we have today
which is c
touch or the exist notion today uh that
we have today because we can't see
it because it uh relies on c and touch
and these two senses
okay and yes uh an object is that
which has shape and exists means that
an object has location once you define
it like that it doesn't matter if it's a
klingon who says it or you
the word table always refers to
an object because a table has shape here
and in the land of the klingons
and does it exist well if it has
location
with respect to other matter in the
universe very objective
definition if it has location then it
exists by definition and not because you
can see
or touch it okay again observation
only muddles the situation observation
is not part of science
observation is testimony and is part of
religion
and whether you did observe or not
an experiment or a phenomenon or
whatever
it doesn't matter it is irrelevant
anyways you don't begin an explanation
which is what science is about
by saying that you observed
i don't know if that sank into some of
these people's brains
okay okay let's get to the subject
matter of today which is
uh bent triangles my god whether
will they invent next warp triangles
okay for this um
we begin with a couple questions that
lingered from the other day which had to
do with parallel lines
okay and some people have problems with
that and it leads to the
issue of today someone says if we extend
parallel line
segments remember what a segment was
it's chopped off at the
edges okay or rays they will be
they will still be parallel okay
if we extend arcs which you see there
okay
uh as you have drawn we have we will
have circle inside of circles we come
back to the same
co-linear point who gave you
the authority who gave you permission
to extend why did you extend my lines
i gave you no permission i assign no
contract to extend any line
more so if it's a line segment right
so this is the problem the problem is
people extend
because they say well a line extends
forever
whatever that is because if the line
extends forever it's not a geometric
figure and if it's one dimensional it's
not a
figure because no diamond no figure is
less than two dimensions or more than
three
okay so what this fellow is talking
about is an itinerary again a bunch of
locations that's why he can
extend it maybe he's talking about the
number line saying there are more
numbers
and numbers are just counting means
again you know motion
so all this is motion so it's got to do
with
not with geometric figures it's got to
do with itineraries and movement
and the spell continues a line is
infinite again
in the infinite line in two
one-dimensional directions
uh one-dimensional i don't know of any
figure that is one-dimensional so if a
line
is one-dimensional it's not a it's not a
geometric figure and if
if if it can be extended infinitely
or to infinity or however you want to
say that then we're not talking about
geometric figure either because
all geometric figures objects
things are those which have
shape and something that is infinite it
doesn't have shape
okay because we're not finished uh
drawing in or
imaging it or whatever you're you're
still sculpting that thing you know
okay so infinite it means really
incessant itinerary
or counting itineraries have no
dimensions
and objects do have dimensions
okay so let's distinguish what these
people are saying with
what geometry is supposed to be founded
on
which is figures things
objects as we call them okay and another
fella
comes up there along the same lines he
says
uh parallel lines are lines angled at
the exact same degree
thus they never meet
two lines with even slightly different
degrees will eventually meet on an
infinite plane all these people talk
about infinities they're lost in
i think it's drugging you know maybe
they inject too much into their veins
they go always to infinity the only way
they won't
is if they both have some the same
degrees
well here i showed the other day a
square which is a plane it's known as a
plane in
science okay and uh we have no use for
it but
uh these are just notions that we have
so we have these figures we call it a
square
and when you say square people think
about that black stuff you see there
and i have two lines on it there are
two-dimensional
okay these two these lines are
two-dimensional you can see they're two
dimensions
not one-dimensional okay we have two
lines
that's what i see in front of it
objectively that's what i see in front
of me
objectively square two lines on a square
two lines uh geometric figures
two dimensional each on a
two-dimensional
square which is what i have objectively
in front of me okay they don't represent
anything
that's what they are okay
let's get that straight first okay so we
have two lines
on a plane they're angled at different
degrees
and they do not meet we're done
are those two lines parallel
and so this is what you got to do you
got to do with what is
objectively in front of you and so this
notion about extending lines to infinity
in planes to infinity
well we can't use that because see there
is no plane
that is infinite no square that i know
of that is infinite no circle that i
know of that is infinite no triangle
that is infinite
and for sure no line that is infinite
all lines
stop there you draw them wherever you
draw them that's where it ends
you got to analyze whatever's in front
of you objectively
and these people you know have little
birdies in their head they say well what
if we
take it to infinity well i've never been
there so i don't know
it's like saying uh what have you
extended to heaven you know
i don't know i've never been there
either and i hope to
a forced all be in there okay so what
was uh my summary the other day let's
start with that
essentially summary for geometry okay
geometry is not a branch of science not
what we have today
not what euclid did that's not part of
science
geometry is a branch of religion
geometry is a branch of religion
okay we got that straight why because
it's an attempt to merge
mathematics with physics that's why and
that's impossible
it's irrational to try to merge math
with physics physics with math
math has to do with counting numbers and
all
uh subsequent developments from there
and physics has to do with objects with
mechanisms
one has nothing to do with the other
you can do all the measurements you want
in math you can calculate you can do
equations
you can do uh derivatives and
integrals algebra whatever
i mean i've done a lot of math and uh i
was good at i like
math a lot but it has nothing to do with
physics
physics is about mechanism tell me how
the window broke
i don't need to know how much how much
mass
how much energy how much force i need to
know what broke it
okay and you can say well like phoenix
did there he threw a brick through it
okay
uh that's how the window broke that's my
theory the window broke because i threw
a brick through it
we're done that's physics it's got
nothing to do with math which is
let me calculate the speed the mass you
know that stuff
one thing has nothing to do with the
other okay
and when we talk about mother nature's
universe we're talking about
physics right we're talking about how
she does things
we want to know we want to understand
how she does gravity how she does
electricity how she does magnetism
not measure and say well this is how
fast she did it or
this is the acceleration of gravity or
or what the
force was you know on the charge or
anything of that nature we don't care
about that that's man
we want to know the we understand the
mechanism how mother nature is doing
these magic tricks
imagine a magician in front of the
audience on the stage saying
uh you know doing his trick and you say
well can you explain that
oh yeah here he did it at so much speed
he got the lady in two pieces
he did a 10 strokes per second
you know i don't care about i want to
know how he did the trick
that's the difference between physics
and math we don't need numbers in
physics
at all okay we're talking about two
different things one is a language which
is math
the other one is a science okay
and so geometries misconceived all
fundamental figures
they misconceived the point the line the
plane the circle the square and the
triangles we saw the other day
okay geometry has to do with measurement
okay math not with figures which is what
physics is
about okay the part we care about
geometry
are the figures okay not how they behave
or what their ratios are what their
relations are
okay so let's get on to the triangle uh
especially the
bent triangle the warp triangle which is
the subject matter today and we start
with euclid's
definition of how he came up with the
triangle itself
what is a triangle we have to first
identify the word triangle
well this is where we have a problem
already okay he says he begins with uh
surface is that which has length and
breadth meaning
again it's not breath it's known as uh
height and width
not even length or breath breath is a
vector not a dimension but
whoever either euclid or his translator
never figured that out
okay the edges of a surface uh are lines
okay uh now the edges of a surface
are known as edges okay not as lines
okay plain surface is a surface which
lies
evenly with the straight lines on itself
so he's gonna make his surfaces
planes okay he's going to make them with
straight lines
no because according to him lines are
discrete
entities and if they're discrete
entities space
separates any two lines i don't care how
many gazillions of lines you put in
between
two lines there's still going to be
space in between there because otherwise
you can't talk about lines
okay so he started off on the wrong foot
already
but he says a boundary is that which is
an extremity of anything okay and he
figures that which is contained by any
boundary
or boundaries perfect the only problem
is he never used that definition
and no one has well that's the first
problem the second problem more
fundamental is no one discovered that
that's
the foundation of physics that that's
how important that definition was
so no one ever discovered that how
important it is
and no one ever used it so irrelevant
anyway so
there it is staring at you in the face
definition number 14
one of the foundations of physics no one
saw it no one understood it no one
figured
that it's important that's where the
problem is
so that's where we start and then he
goes on to define what a triangle is he
says rectilinear figures are those which
are contained by straight lines okay
which is not true but
trilateral figures being those contained
by three and then he continues on
uh with other uh rectilinear figures
and he just goes into definition 20 and
21 into different types of triangles
so what is a triangle well it's a
three-sided
thing figure whatever you want to call
it
okay so we started off there but did we
improve on that well no we only got it
worse because we got all these wrong
here we have the circle we talked about
the other day
it's just an orbit of a location not
even of a
point because the point is a location
and here we have the square
okay and what is a square well a square
is
a path around a perimeter again it's
just a bunch of locations
that's all that it means to a a
mathematician
not a physicist and here we have the
triangle
triangles not even that triangle you
don't even need three sides today did
you find it's just three points
if you have three points you have a
triangle
so that's a triangle according to them
i don't know that doesn't look like a
triangle to me it looks like three
points
three disconnected points that's what
they look like to me but this is what
they say is a triangle
so this is where we already start on the
wrong foot if that's a triangle well
yeah i can see how they got
lost over time okay and um
important here euclid essentially um
said that his triangles the plane
triangle
triangle three angles right amount to
180 degrees
and here it is okay this is just one
example he
he wrote a lot of propositions and etc
okay
and he tried to prove them what they
call mathematical proofs
okay and proposition number nine just an
example here okay to bisect a given
rectilinear
angle and what he does is he chops a
triangle in half and he just
figures out that they're rectilinear
angles so
both of them meaning 90 degrees and the
two sides essentially
of that triangle uh equal 180 degrees
so through this uh proposition and
others
you can look at the whole series
especially in book one
and you'll find out that essentially
he's talking about 180 degrees
okay it's all related to 180 degrees
we're done
right now it was too boring
it was too boring and so they had to
change that and that change started in
the
early you would say the first half of
the 19th century okay
and it started with this fellow his name
is nikolai
lobaczewski okay and he uh one day he
took his
triangle which he put on a piece of
paper i guess right
and by mistake you know he happened to
put it on his on the saddle of his horse
and when he did that he found out hey
you know it no longer has 180 degrees
it's got something different than 180
degrees
well another fella came around a few
years later
again 19th century still his name was uh
bernhard greenman and raymond instead he
put it on a soccer ball i guess right
and he said hold it this piece of paper
which
i had it flat on my table now i put it
on my
soccer ball and the ankles seem to have
grown bigger of course neither
riemann nor um uh
lobochevsky realized that
you know they were they were encroaching
on the third dimension
see if you take a square and you twist
it around
like you know now you're you don't have
it on the same plane you don't have just
width and height but now you twist it in
such a way that
you also give it some depth in others
meaning
you gave it the third dimension which in
this case is length
well now you have length width and
height so that
square is now in three dimensions and
just because you tilted it
assuming you know you could have a
square in the middle of space right
god can do that and if you twist it
around it's no longer a square
now it becomes a rectangle and you can
do that with with almost any figure if
you
turn a circle around right if you could
get a circle a two-dimensional circle
right and you have
width and height and you turn it around
such that you know from the
viewer's point of view it now occupies a
third
dimension well you no longer have a
circle now you have an oval
yeah and it changes its shape
and so the question is are you allowed
to do that
well this is what these folks did they
they put their triangles
into the third dimension they bent it
into the third dimension
okay and it's like oh ho ho yeah we did
it
okay so now we have a difference and
what did these gentlemen conclude
lobochevsky and raymond well this is
what they concluded essentially
again in a nutshell they said look
when i put it on my horseback i get less
than 180 degrees
and the other guy says well you're wrong
see when i put on my
football soccer ball or whatever
baseball
uh basketball um
i get more than 180 degrees especially
if it's malleable
right unfortunately you know they don't
make triangles which are
not malleable and so when they do that
it says i get more than 180 degrees and
they started messing around
with triangles which are not triangles
not in the
in the old-fashioned way and again
triangle means
three angles right and they say well
so if you got more than 180 degrees here
and you got less than 180 degrees there
and they said yeah
see the way they calculate those angles
now
is they take the tangents they take two
of the tangents and
and they calculate that separation
between the tangents
like you know if you put a tangent there
on the on the uh
ball on the triangle triangle the
riemann triangle
that's on the ball you know uh you just
take any point it doesn't matter
along that curve and just take two
points put a tangent there and that's
how you calculate the angle
at that point okay so that's how they do
it
in general terms okay so that gives you
an idea how
the math developed from this from this
notion
that these folks had
so you say well bill what's the problem
with that i mean
geometry it's measurement it's
calculations it's angles
it's uh sine cosine and all that kind of
stuff
trigonometry you know that's good stuff
uh what's wrong with that what's wrong
with uh
giving it a new notion to the triangle
and to the these lines well i'll tell
you
one of the problems uh there's a couple
problems but i'll give you one other
problem
one of them they ended up with curved
dimensions
okay and uh here you have an idea
of what these people did okay
see euclid had these straight dimensions
length with and height
were done simple everybody understood it
these folks came up with the curved
dimensions essentially
yeah you have curved width curved length
and curved curved height
and that complicated things a little bit
because you know now we have a
different language they they put a new
language starting in the 19th century
which is you know
these curved lines because they're
they have to account for how they
reshaped
the triangle okay
and
you say well still what's the problem
with that
and here's the problem here's the
problem though one big problem okay and
it's known as the geodesic
okay geodesic is a curved dimension it's
a curved
uh yeah a curved dimension essentially
remember the circle well they say a
circle has no
uh no insides it's got no guts
circle is just a circumference it's not
this it's not a disc
people criticize me and say well bill
but yours is
is a disc it's not a circle well we call
it a circle
because the disc
uh or the circle one of those two words
is too much is is
irrelevant because if the circle is just
the circumference we call it
circumference
if the circle is the disk we call it a
disk
then why do we need the word circle for
this so they say well the circle is that
what you see there
uh just the outside the perimeter
and remember it's a bunch of dots okay
because it's and those dots represent
location
meaning that what you're staring at is
just a bunch of locations you're
staring at an orbit and so now the
question is okay so we have this circle
let's even assume if you want
that's contoured by a solid line
continuous
line okay so far is it good
now i want to get from a to b
very simple right well i want to take
the shortest
path the shortest path is a straight
line we call it a rectilinear
itinerary not a straight line because
we're not talking about lines geometric
lines we're talking about itineraries
which is another issue okay but i take
the
shortcut across you know the red one
there
and they say you can you got to take the
one on the outside
and i say why that's that's longer
no no it's the shortest path
what do you mean the shortest path the
shortest path is the red line
the red line the red dotted line and
they say well
see not on a curved surface
well but you don't need to do that with
a circle because a circle has no
guts it's got nothing in it it's um
it's empty on the inside of the
circumference
why can't you take a shortcut
and they extrapolate this notion to
things like the earth like you know
a sphere perfect spear again
is empty on the inside it's a solid that
is
uh hollow a hollow
solid okay that's what a sphere is
so if a sphere is a hollow solid why
can't i cut across
the inside if it's there's nothing there
to stop me why do i have to go through
the surface
well that's when they say well you can't
do it on the earth
that's why you need a geodesic because
on the earth
you have to the shortest path is not
through the earth
uh you know like going to the center of
the earth no you got to go around the
surface so that's how the geodesic was
introduced
and now you can see also the idea of
bent triangles
lying like on the earth on a
solid which is not hollow okay
this is where we're getting to this and
we ended up with something like this
if i can get it here
part of it is language let me let me
cover that real quick first
okay and uh just like you know you don't
do rectilinear
you don't do straight lines you do
rectilinear itineraries
and you say well that's semantics that's
just wording
well see they have all this rotten
wording everywhere you know spin is not
spam
particle is not particle okay in
mathematical physics
and then we have situations like this
one where you have nasa and they say
i just took a snapshot of this from by
googling it you know in the image
region okay says nasa
how gravity warps light
another one by astronomy.com bent light
if photons have no mass blah blah blah
blah okay
nasa how gravity warps light okay
and another one gravity must bend light
so we have warped and bent light
and is that what we're saying we're
wiping a photon we're
we're bending a photon we're taking a
little photon just bending it in half
warping it is that what these people are
saying
no they're using the wrong language what
they're saying it's been deflected
they're saying that a series of folks in
fact they draw it a whole bunch of
photons right little particles that
supposedly represent a ray of light
and it curves around it is warped around
right because it's not really warped or
bent what it what you're having is it's
being deflected supposedly by the
warpage
of space-time which is alleged to be a
physical object
you have this warped time and the little
photon is sliding along
warp time and it's not being bent
or warped that space time that's warped
or bent what's with the little photon
has been
doing is it's being deflected okay
so language is important and again we
have that same problem when they confuse
rectilinear with straight
or curvilinear with curve you know
curved uh you can say that a hammock
or a banana is curved uh
but when you're talking about
itineraries now you're talking about
something else you're talking about
rectilinear it's something moving right
to
linearly or curvilinearly
okay you're talking about how it moves
not not you're not talking about its
structure
and so the language is important
especially when you're talking about
geometry which
is about figures but since these people
don't talk about figures they just talk
about itineraries
which they represent with figures
okay and you're not supposed to take the
figure literally
well that's where they get confused
instead of talking about the motion
they they say straight no you don't move
straight
straight except in ordinary speech in
science you have to say rectilinearly
okay that's how motion is okay and so
now yeah you can see how they
uh how these bent triangles and
geodesics
uh create big problems because here you
have two elephants
okay and they're moving along geodesics
in other words they're moving
along curved path the shortest path and
it turns out that they say that
this is what causes them to be attracted
to each other this is the mechanism of
gravity the mechanism of attraction
they say that because they move along
geodesics that's to cause the mechanism
of attraction
so you can see how dangerous all this
stuff is because that's not an
explanation that's not a you can't say
that that's the mechanism that brought
these two
elephants together that's a description
that says that
if they moved along these two curved
surfaces on a sphere
they get closer together that's a
description that's not a cause that's
not a mechanism
you see how dangerous the language is
and why geometry
having been misconceived from the start
ends up with these kinds of conclusions
okay so yes it is important it's more
than language it's conceptual
okay we've lost track
of what we're talking about because
these people are introducing
motion in the guise of objects
they represent them with objects then
they can get confused
between the object that represents the
motion
and then they use the wrong language
because they're they're describing
the object not understanding that
they're actually describing
motion and you don't use adjectives to
describe
motion you use adverbs to describe to
describe motion to qualify motion
this is where it gets so dangerous
because people get lost in
what they're really talking about so
when they talk about particle you think
a particle yeah i know what a particle
is a particle is like a
speck of dust a grain of sand and so
they talk about the motion of the
particle and they
give a two hour dissertation then you
say well was that
really a particle and they said well
you're not supposed to take
the analogy literally no it wasn't a
particle it was the collapse of the wave
function that was moving
they're talking about a number they're
talking about an equation they're
talking about a function
and they're talking about the location
how you can locate
the particle the so-called particle the
location how they can locate the
location in a certain location that's
what they're talking about
and so yeah after a while you get dizzy
you don't understand at all what they're
talking about
they don't and they don't either they
think they give a physical
interpretation
okay uh let me move on to questions
and comments we have a few of those okay
one fellow says
get it up here i says
magnetism isn't in motion he doesn't
think there's anything in motion
inside that so-called magnetic field
let's observe the experiment you posted
with
iron filings okay let me put that up
there maybe
give me a second here
got it here
okay here it is okay let me put it over
here i'll
block my head okay
okay so you can see that the iron
filings whether they're in the water
in the case of the one above or the ones
that spring out of a
canvas that is a little trampled in
there you can see the iron filings are
picked up one
at a time if you look carefully you'll
see they're pulled one
at a time just look at any one arm
values or a couple of them and you'll
see how
they're being drawn towards the magnet
one at a time
and so this fellow doesn't believe that
that's happening
in motion that there's no motion going
on in there even though there is motion
going on in there
what do you call that don't you call
that motion i mean it looks like every
iron filing is being pulled
one by one moving towards
the uh towards the magnet okay
but he says that magnetism isn't in
motion let's observe those remember
you posted with iron filings that's what
i posted okay
says yes they came in one by one
and the furthest the way came to rest
last well i don't care
about that we want to know what physical
object came in contact with the iron
filing
and he mentions later on i don't know if
this is what he's proposing he says
the vortex coil uh
and that's what a vortex coil looks like
i put the little three eggs there
because i
think it was kind of you know hollow
and i thought maybe this nest could use
three little eggs there
but yeah there you see what a vortex
coil looks like i guess that's what it
is referring to and okay so that's what
came in contact with
one iron filing there i have them drawn
at the bottom
there you see a little corner of the
magnet
i put the positive end there and that's
just a little corner tiny corner
very small and i guess it throws a
vortex
coil at the iron filing is this with
this
fellow proposing he's throwing this nest
this
little donut at the iron filing
assuming that's the case i'm not going
to put words in his mouth but assuming
that's the case
i guess he's saying that somehow that
pulls the arm filing towards the magnet
if it does if that's what he's proposing
i want to know what the mechanism is
and then yes if that vortex coil has to
fly out of the magnet to reach the iron
filings to bring it in
i would say that vortex coil is in
motion
which is what we observe on the right
every iron filing is being uh
drawn somehow either pushed or pulled
towards the magnet
so i need to know what came in contact
with the i
with one iron filing don't tell me that
it did i know that it did
he says yes they came in one by one and
then he just drops he doesn't tell me
what came in contact with it and this is
where the problem is these people are
avoiding the question because they have
no answer
and regarding uh whether something is in
motion all we can do is put
a little authority here people respect
the authority here we have
mr michael faraday and also mr
uh james maxwell and uh
michael fairley said i cannot conceive
curved lines of force without
the condition of a physical presence
a physical existence okay so he says
there's something physical in motion
there
and then uh james maxwell said is that
in that space there is matter
what in motion and i think maxwell knew
a little more than this poor fellow
about the
magnetism and uh how what magnets do
okay so uh yeah you gotta find out uh
first that a field is has something in
motion
in it field is made of something that is
in motion so even though the field is
there always standing still
you know so to speak because you throw
the iron filings they're all there and
they just stay there
when when you just sprinkle over uh iron
filings over a magnet
that's different when you can see in
slow motion how they're pulled
one at a time so that so-called field is
not
standing still there's something in
motion that makes up the field
and hopefully it's a physical object for
otherwise you're putting spirits in that
same space you're telling me that it's
done by magic
so yeah there is something in motion in
there and that's what james maxwell and
uh
faraday said they did a lot of
experiments with uh
magnus they reached that conclusion i
think anyone who would any rational
person would
reach a conclusion that there's
something in motion in there
which is pulling one iron filing at a
time you gotta identify whatever came in
contact with the surface
of the iron filing just like you have to
identify the
object that comes in contact with the
surface of the earth
and prevents it from leaving the solar
system
and it's all this invisible intangible
stuff we have to identify
okay that's what it's all about that's
what science physics is about
okay so uh what do we propose well here
it is
and you've seen this um we propose that
uh magnets have these threads that are
moving around and those threads make up
the magnetic field
so even though the field you can say
static what's moving inside the field
is these threads they move in the same
direction on top and on the bottom
uh you have a traction and you turn the
magnet upside down and
nothing changes they're still attracting
each other because nothing has changed
in the
clockwise and counterclockwise
directions but when you turn the magnet
the first magnet
180 degrees east to west
now you have repulsion because the top
one is going clockwise against
counterclockwise and vice versa at the
bottom
okay here it is again you have clockwise
counterclockwise against
counterclockwise and clockwise against
clockwise and they attract
if you swi rotate the magnet nothing
changes you still have north again south
you still have counterclockwise against
counterclockwise and clockwise against
cloud clouds
it's only when you turn the magnet in
the
east-west direction that you have south
again south
that now they push each other away
a very simple uh mechanism
and we're talking about mechanisms here
we're not talking about belief
we're talking about here you have a
mechanism you can take to the bank
whether you believe in it or not we
don't care it's not part of science
we're just explaining a mechanism so
that you understand
okay if you understood it we're done
with science what continues
is known as religion belief
okay um another question another
issue fellow says
says if we are all connected the
rope model proposes there that all atoms
in the universe
are interconnected okay there is no
touch
the touch would only be a reaction
let's call it so for simplicity between
two h
atoms or two groups of h atoms that form
two objects for example
well you got to be careful again the
word touch is very touchy
okay there's touch of ordinary speech
and there is scientific definite
scientific definition of touch their
scientific touch
and ordinary speech touch these are not
the same
in ordinary speech you say i touch the
table you put the finger against the
table and you say i touched it
we're done nobody cares everybody
understands
that very general statement
when you come into science you ask a
quantum mechanic you say did that adam
touch that other atom
and he's going to give you a different
uh definition than what you have in
ordinary speech he says well look you
have this field
and i'm going to talk to you about touch
not being touched like you think touch
is two surfaces coming together because
it's not like the atom comes in contact
with another atom according to them
right
it's that we have these fields whatever
fields are
okay and uh fields don't touch each
other because they're like
concepts mathematical concepts so you
don't have
mathematical concepts touch other
mathematical context
concepts so again the
now that it's no longer the touch of
ordinary speech that you touch the table
with your finger now they give you the
run around okay now they
say well touch is not touching quantum
mechanics
okay and we have more or less a similar
explanation we're saying that
for the purposes of science
you cannot use the notion of ordinary
speech
okay so what uh what are we talking
about well here
i gave an example i'm going to give it
one more time here
okay here it is let me put it over here
what are we saying he's saying do atoms
come together
yeah they do come together why because
an atom eats up
reels in the rope the electromagnetic
rope that can
interconnect any two atoms one atom
that's
sliding towards another one slides
towards it as
the threads work around it one thread
goes around
forms the magnetic uh the uh electric
um shell electric membrane
which is the this spherical membrane
that encapsulates the proton star which
is
the other thread going through the
center of the
uh atom so all the uh threads from
every rope in the universe converging
upon our atom form the
proton star that's how it's built and
then that's encapsulated by
the electron membrane that's the simple
hydrogen atom
so when one hydrogen atom moves towards
another
the ropes uh fork out at the boundary of
the atom
and they slide around and there you see
an example on the bottom we put a hand
and i've illustrated five atoms one for
each finger
just one atom okay obviously they're a
lot smaller than that okay so i made
them big so you can see them
and when you slide your hand
perpendicular to the ball
okay what you're doing all those atoms
that form your fingers they're just
sliding through the ropes
you can't touch the ropes because you're
already touching them
so to speak you know they end on each
one of the atoms
so you're just sliding through the ropes
and you're reeling
all that rope into you and sending it
behind you
you're just sliding your hand through
the ropes that's why you can't touch the
ropes
but when you reach an atom like you know
the one that forms your table
or whatever in this case the ball now
you have atom against adam
and we can call that touch okay
what does touch mean well it's a little
tricky because what we're saying
is the surface of one
electron membrane which is again
globular like
you see there more or less touches the
electron shell of another
and there is no rope between them so now
you have
surface of one electron shell
against surface of another electron
shell
not field against field not electron
bead against electron bead
you have a membrane that is pushing up
against another membrane because there
is no rope between them the rope
has essentially become you know gone
completely out
remember one reels in the rope as they
move
across the slide across the rope
so you have a surface of electron shell
against surface of electron shell with
no rope between them
that we call touch and yeah when you get
that
um then you do have touch
between two atoms you can't touch the
rope
you can touch atoms okay so i hope that
answers your question that's the
explanation for touch what does touch
mean in the absolute
two objects have become one
what do i mean by that well in the case
of hydrogen you know you can have
two hydrogen atoms and they form the
hydrogen
molecule h2 you heard of that
what does it mean well it means you form
this figure eight
one atom should have brought it maybe
i'd put it some other day
but you have these two figure eights
like two balls essentially like this
okay that's that's essentially what it
looks like okay
two two balls so we have one electron
membrane against another electron
membrane okay
and they form this figure eight and
they're
siamese tween twins they're uh
united by their belly buttons so to
speak
okay they share a belly button these two
objects have become one a figure eight
in this case molecule so
touch is two objects becoming
one okay science
not not ordinary speech because people
say well does that mean that if i touch
the table
no no now you're going back into
ordinary speech we're talking about
scientific language
language that you can use consistently
rationally okay
what we're saying is the two hydrogen
atoms share the same belly button
okay they're siamese twins uh they
become a figure eight
shape uh membrane they were
two ball shaped membranes now they're a
figure eight shaped
membrane one object okay
that's how uh that's what the h2
molecule is it's one object
okay and then obviously it squishes even
further but that's a long story
okay uh one follow says
science is well defined whoa is it
and it would be more correct for you to
use whenever you've pronounced the word
science to add
rational in front of it right rational
science
we do that it's not necessary and i
really discourage it
i suggest that he call his proposal
rational science to clearly distinguish
it from traditional
science okay so what's the problem the
problem is science is not well defined
at all
we don't have a definition of the word
science we never had
okay that's where the problem starts so
we have to what is broken we have to fix
and so science is defined as a process
and it ain't
a process doesn't give you understanding
science is understanding explanation and
understanding
if you do a process and you just study
you just do research
you did an experiment well it doesn't
mean you learned anything
you know again i might go to experiment
someone said he liked it
i let go of the pencil i went to prove
to
observe to do gravity to what do you
experiment in gravity
let go of it foster the floor okay we're
done right
you want to do it twice so it's
scientific repeatable okay we let go
another pencil
there it goes they always fall to the
floor to the table what's underneath
uh so because i did an experiment i
observed
what did i learn does that mean i can
explain gravity
so yeah just a process
observation doing experiments collecting
data
presenting evidence none of that has
anything to do with science because that
doesn't tell you
whether the guy understood anything
whether he learned anything
that's why it's not part of science
science hopefully is
some progress made in understanding of
how the universe runs how mother nature
does her magical stuff her invisible
intangible stuff
okay we have science today defined for
research i covered that earlier
also defined for persuasion i covered
that earlier that's
religion okay persuading
religion now you're just trying to
convince the jury to vote for your
theory
to your explanation or whatever whether
it's irrational or not doesn't matter
you know so if all the people on the on
the planet vote for your theory does
that make it right
does that is that how mother nature does
things because everybody voted for your
theory
so now all that is religion we don't
that's belief
and uh since science is misdefined
undefined we need to fix the definition
okay so yeah i know uh right now we
don't have a definition of science
we uh but if you have one please put it
out there and you'll see how easy it's
to tear
it is to tear it down okay so we need to
define science and that's continue using
something that is broken
we need to fix it okay next question
uh issue talks about knowledge
and fellow says uh in your opinion
knowing is synonymous with believing
uh no that's not my opinion this is not
my opinion it's plato's
opinion which is the definition we have
today which is
justified true belief knowledge is a
belief not according to bill gates it's
a
belief according to that man plato and
everyone who came after
we're still using that definition
justified true belief that means if
you're justified
to have that belief then that's known as
knowledge
for you because someone else has
different knowledge
some people know that god exists the
other guy knows that god doesn't exist
so everybody knows but they have
contradictions that means i guess nobody
knows
or like the three stooges used to say uh
mo s
larry says can you do that and there he
says
uh no he says do you think you can do
that
and uh there he says i don't think i
know
and moe says yeah i don't think you know
either
that's more or less this is what this is
about knowledge has nothing to do with
science because knowledge is an opinion
it's belief
now this belongs to religion when you
know
okay say it there um it means that
you've already made up your
mind doesn't mean the other guy has made
up
his mind in the same way that you made
up your mind that's why knowledge has
nothing to do with science even though
the word science
derives from you know sierra which is
the latin word for knowledge
science has nothing to do with knowledge
and the
romans and greeks set us on the wrong
path that's what we got to say and
that's why we have to
redefine the word science because it's
never been
really defined okay so now it's another
version of it
you'll find out there acquaintance with
facts and truths etcetera etcetera
what are truth verified facts what are
facts
something known and
a truth which is known so we have
circular definitions for the word
knowledge truth and fact
they all mean the same thing they're
synonyms and they define one in terms of
the other
so no we don't have definition for the
word knowledge today we're still using
justified true belief if knowledge is
belief it has nothing
to do with science sorry uh
we define knowledge there for you so
that you can learn a little bit
the ability to predict the outcome of an
experiment without air
that's what knowledge has always meant
whether people defined it like that or
not that's the real
notion of knowledge how do you prove
uh to your professors at the university
well you run an experiment see i can
tell you what's going to happen if i mix
red with
blue it's going to go kaboom
okay show us kaboom
we have knowledge and we're at the
hospital now
okay so that's how you prove knowledge
by running an experiment
and predicting in advance what's going
to happen then you can say you know
you cannot use the word knowledge in
terms of history you cannot say i know
that caesar went to england
no you don't know please prove it
well here it's in the book you know i
mean and here's another book says jesus
went to heaven and came back and
you know i mean do you know
no you're you're just reading you're
just regurgitating what you memorize
that's not knowledge
knowledge only has to do with the future
when you predict something will happen
then you show
that you know okay so yeah the word
knowledge has never been defined i had
to define it
because people thought they knew what
knowledge means and there is the ability
to predict
the outcome of an experiment without air
that's what knowledge
is and that's not what science does but
science doesn't do predictions
we don't care what horse is going to win
the race okay we don't make prediction
no betting allowed in science
okay uh final issue fella says
about good old miss ayn rand ein rand
ayn rand
ran considers the act of perceiving
existence by
sensorial system as insufficient
to acquire objective knowledge
knowledge again jesus she explicitly
agrees with you
about how only using the perceptual
faculty as the standard of knowledge
leads to a subjectivism
i don't think so i still don't
understand why the hell you don't grasp
the fact that metaphysics means the
study of laws
of existence okay so let's answer this
gentleman
see if i can get the answer from way
down at the bottom here give me a second
there it goes
okay here we go
okay so what does bill gates say well
the word knowledge belongs exclusively
to religion knowledge equals belief as i
just
stated and when you know for sure a
proven fact
you have a belief opinion
in other words religion but this is what
aim rand said in her
book introduction to objectivist
epistemology
1966-1967 she wrote in a series of
articles
and they compiled it into a book and she
says the following
listen carefully because apparently some
people don't know how to read very well
or have problems with reading
comprehension she says
all knowledge is processed knowledge
whether on the sensory perceptual or
conceptual
level and unprocessed knowledge would be
a knowledge
acquired without means of what cognition
okay so no she said exactly the opposite
that you need
perceptual faculty you need perception
in order to acquire knowledge that's
what ain't rand said
okay so you should read her stuff
because you got
it exactly the opposite of what she said
and then uh metaphysics well
we don't know what that is in science uh
we have only two branches one is known
as physics the other one is philosophy
and the words object and exist
exclusively
to physics so what this metaphysics
uh little thingy is ontology we don't
know what all that is
uh it's got nothing to do with nothing
uh not a branch of physics
certainly not a branch of philosophy
okay philosophy doesn't deal with
object or existence at all those words
belong exclusively to physics
philosophy deals with behaviors
of humans explaining behavior maybe
of some animal as well you know you can
explain the behavior
of an animal you can say why the animal
did such and such thing
why did the lion eat the deer well he
was hungry i don't know
uh those are questions of philosophy the
purpose and reasons someone uh
behaves in a certain way and that
involves in many
many disciplines including history why
someone went
why napoleon went to waterloo as i
always say okay uh
physics deals with objects and
things uh and things that exist
okay things uh objects and existence
belong exclusively to physics
so as long as we keep them separated we
can talk
in an organized manner in a rational
manner it's when we confuse these things
say well that belongs to ontology
and i went to metaphysics and i don't
know if this is philosophy
yeah no we have to define these
categories very
rigidly okay so that we do not step
over the boundaries okay like you know
in religion people say well
uh belief in god well that's a question
of religion
meaning the belief in the existence of
god
no that's not an issue of religion it's
an issue of physics
whether god exists or not is an issue
that concerns only
physics because physics has a monopoly
over the word exist
anyone claiming the existence of et's of
god or whatever
he's crossed the line into physics
whether he knows it or not
okay so for that you need to define the
word exists so that you can use it
consistently and you can apply it
to whatever you're going to say to your
dissertation to your theory
and for that you got to define it
especially because physics is
the science of existence you must
okay with that i'll see you next time
and
i hope you have a great